the new Snow White Lady
who is who is notably not white so we
call her sand beige
Sandy Tope
this lady is thrilled that they're
remaking Snow White not just in the new
casting decisions but remaking the whole
movie because she says that Snow White
is dated
cartoon was made 85 years ago and
therefore it's extremely dated when it
comes to the ideas of women being in
roles of power and uh and what a woman
is fit for in the world and so when we
came to reimagining the actual role of
Snow White it became about the fairest
of them all meaning who is the most just
and who can become a fantastic leader
and the reality is you know Snow White
has to learn a lot of lessons about
coming into her own power before she can
come into power over a kingdom also the
fact that she's not going to be saved by
The Prince and she's the proactive one
and she's the one who said the terms
um is what makes it so relevant to where
we are today
not even going to comment on the way
that they've Rewritten the script
to take out all those terrible things
like Beauty and love you know who wants
Snow White with beauty and love when we
can talk about girl bosses when isn't
that captivating can't you wait to just
run out to the theaters and get your
popcorn and no I don't think so forget
that for a second
she says they rewrote the story because
Snow White is extremely dated
what does that mean to be dated
she's saying it like it's a bad thing
it's bad to be dated
isn't it only bad
for a thing to be dated
if the time that we are living in is
better than the time that the dated
thing
existed in
in other words
if if we were living in in this
wonderful age where everyone was
thriving and things were beautiful and
just and good and virtuous and and then
you looked back it's at some other time
in history
and you pointed to some Vestige of that
and you said oh that's so dated from
that time and that other time was a
really awful terrible time and when
everything was ugly and decaying and
vicious and evil and
well then then it would be bad for
something to be dated to that time but
what if
the time that we were living in right
now is worse by almost every measure
than the time
to which this thing we're criticizing is
dated then dated would be a good thing
and then we'd say oh that's so dated
from this much better time that can
maybe give us a guide post as to how to
get out of the dumb age that we're
living in
buy virtually every measure by virtually
every measure
1937 was a better time that was more
conducive to human flourishing and
virtue than today is
and and we can look through all the
social scientific data on this
we're not having any kids anymore the
civilization is literally dying people
are much more depressed people are much
more anxious the suicide rates are much
higher people are reporting much lower
rates of happiness and satisfaction you
look at all the social science
and then you look at the harder facts
should we see a little bit in people
we're having bigger families people were
were
building beautiful things the culture
was physically more beautiful you had
better buildings better artwork coming
up yet you had people therefore a little
more hopeful about the future
what you're always going to hear when
you bring that up is people to say yeah
but you know back in the past
some sort of unpleasant feature of the
past as I see
and and if in the case of 1937 that's
pretty much it this is before World War
II got the end of the Great Depression
on the horizon and by the way material
hardship is not
not intrinsically immoral or anything
like that but
but even then
yeah you say okay well what about that
huh back in back then they had different
water fountains for white and black
people okay now we kill 800 000 babies a
year now we chop little kids genitals
off now we don't have any hope for the
future or any patriotism the rates of
those things are declining precipitously
now we don't have National borders now
we don't speak the same language now we
now we this now we that oh did I mention
we kill 800 000 babies a year you're
really going to tell me oh no we're
living in the best time you just don't
understand this is what the Liberals
always say the Liberals on the left and
even the Liberals on the right
the the kind of center-right people oh
come on let's stop complaining we're
living in the best time they often adopt
the premises and the language of the
left no
1937 America had its act much more
together than it does now
white is dated yeah I guess so let's go
watch that movie maybe we can learn a
thing or two right now go to
grillblazer.com Knowles use promo code
Knowles Grill Blazers Grill guns are
designed to do everything from lighting
my cigars to lighting my other cigars
you could also use them to expertly sear
your meat Light charcoal grills wood
stoves after fireplaces just about
anything you can think of for which you
would need high power Fire Grill Blazers
offers two types of Grill guns the grill
gun basic is a high power propane torch
designed to Light charcoal and wood
grills and smokers burns up to 3 600
Degrees which is the average temperature
of Phoenix Arizona in the month of July
its 30 inch flame is for anything that
you need a big bad torch to do and then
there's the cute little sous-vide gun
it's got a little bit of a shorter
Barrel perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen uses from gently carbonizing
Blu-ray or other sugars and fruits to
rapidly searing steaks outside on the
grill using the grill gun may result in
extreme Grill Envy from your neighbors
so user discretion advised get your
grill gun from Grill Blazers today let
the grilling Adventures begin
rollblazer.com Knowles use promo code
nulls for 15 off your order
grillblazer.com promo code notes for 15
off your order dog meat farmers in South
Korea are pushing back on a potential
ban South Korea wants to ban dog meat
I don't like dogs
I don't some people ask are you a dog
person are you a cat person I'm not I'm
a people person I like people
I don't really care for pets that much I
don't hate them I don't they don't make
me angry but I just don't like them
and yet
people should not eat dog Libs think we
should be able to eat dogs utilitarians
think we ought to be able to eat dogs
materialists think we ought to be able
to eat dogs because you know it's just
meat these people probably think we
should eat humans
but we should not eat dogs
and the reason it's wrong to eat dogs
and the reason the South Korean dog
farmers are wrong and the reason that
the people trying to reform this are
right is because that's not what dogs
are for
dogs are there to be man's best friend
they're not my best friend but broadly
they are man's best friend they were
bred to be man's best friend
and that's why it's especially cruel in
a way that it's not cruel to kill a
needed cow killing a pig killing any
chicken
the dogs are there and we're bred even
if you just want to look at a purely
historical evolutionary kind of view of
it to say nothing of a deeper
philosophical View
they're there to be our mate and our
help and our buddies and our Companions
and it's wrong to eat them that's why
that's why it feels wrong to eat a dog
I've never tried eating a dog but that's
why I would not be inclined to eat a dog
even though I don't like them all that
much
it's the C.S Lewis argument for it it's
not that dogs have rights they don't
it's not that animals have rights
broadly they don't
but when we when we do things like
torture animals or when we do things
like eat dogs
it deadens our Humanity
because we are violating a kind of
metaphysical Concord that we have with
with dogs and we're violating the proper
order of Nature and and the ends to
which these things are ordered boy what
a great clip that was now make sure you
ring that Bell subscribe to this very
YouTube channel
see you next time